[Music]
how are you guys doing it's been a long
time yes it has Ramadan Mubarak to you
too let's start proceedings actually by
reminding each other and giving each
other opportunity to give charity now
one um is a fantastic charity they're
doing work all over the world and they
are delivering these Food Packs you see
with the essentials things like rice and
barley and oil and these kind of things
to people most needy around the world in
places like Pakistan and Afghanistan and
Somalia in Morocco in different parts of
the world and I think it's only right
that we do our part yes it's only right
that we do our part and click the link
below only take a few seconds and
imagine the immeasurable kinds of
rewards that we'll get by giving charity
to these places so let's not forget to
do that pornography pornography is a
very pernicious kind of addiction
actually in the new age just like many
other addictions and what are addictions
addictions usually are defined as some
kind of behavior or some kind of pattern
which is harmful to the individual yet
the person has quote unquote no control
over it yet we do have a lot of control
over addictions and those addictions are
usually overcome by willpower now this
is a very controversial thing for many
people they'll say no we don't believe
in willpower can if you're addicted to
something you literally have no control
this is bogus in my my opinion having
said this let's take a look at some of
the scientific workings out of
pornography addiction in particular and
come back and respond and discuss in
kind though it's not a physical
substance it leads to the same general
loss of control the compulsiveness to
seek out the activity despite negative
consequences and withdraw when it goes
away much like that of gambling or
running for example the issue is that
continued exposure can cause long-term
or even lifelong neuroplastic change in
the brain dopamine is released as a
reward when whenever we accomplish
something whether it be eating to
sustain life or sexual activity to
produce future life and this dopamine
consolidates neural Connections in order
to drive us to perform the same activity
in the future now as you see there there
is and there has been many different
kinds of things that have been kind of
different studies in biology in
physiology in Psychology relating to
addiction and pornography addiction and
sex addiction in particular in fact I
read a book just recently called
dopamine nation which now has been a fad
I would say focused on the
neurotransmitter dopamine and its
effects and basically as you saw in the
video there the idea is the more you
consume of pornography the more you'll
need and it's it's interesting because
it's meant to give you a pleasurable
effect but it's actually giving you the
opposite because the more you consume of
it the more you won't feel pleasure by
doing things which would otherwise give
you pleasure and so the first reason why
somebody should really consider quitting
pornography as an addiction is because
it actually has the adverse effect this
is a very interesting thing it has the
adverse effect so if you're doing this
for pleasure then in the long run the
opposite will happen to you that you'll
get no pleasure out of it in fact it
will stop you from having pleasure
because it will do it will it will blun
in your dopamine receptors so it can be
something of a pathetic irony that
someone is Seeking a kind of heathenism
but is in fact getting what you call
anhedonia which is the opposite of
Hedonism which is your inability to feel
pleasure through the same exact way in
which you think you're getting the
pleasure from so the first reason as I
say is because it has the adverse effect
the second reason is because it actually
disturbs your mind and your ability to
do hard work in other fields now if you
as if you're an addict to something if
you're an addict to for example
pornography or weed or any kind of thing
whereby you need something and you feel
a loss of control now that can't be good
for you and this is spelled out in some
copious detail in the book The the dopam
mination which I can't get into now
because of brevity and
conciseness and the third reason I would
say the most important from our
perspective as Muslims is because of ta
because of
Purity Allah says in Quran that the one
who has purified himself has
already succeeded so it's a kind of
purification process where you remove
from yourself the impediments of
watching and consuming something like
pornography now Ramadan is a really good
opportunity for us to do this it's a
it's a month of fasting it's a month
where you're depriving yourself and
you're controlling yourself and you're
increasing your willpower and as I say
willpower According to some new age
psychological theories can actually be
increased it can be worked on like a
muscle and I refer you to a book written
by Roy Bal Meister called willpower
actually very interesting one where he
talks about something called the ego
depletion model but he also talks about
the fact that yes the threshold for
willpower can increase and so the
strongest antidote you see for something
like pornography or any kind of
addiction is in fact willpower and the
month of Ramadan is a month where you're
meant to expand your process or your
expand your ability to have willpower
your sa your resilience you
see
that
be that seek patience and prayer
patience and resilience this is
something that Ramadan is trying to
Foster within you and this is the best
opportunity so the three reasons once
again number one because it actually has
the adverse effect number two because
it'll make you a weaker person and
addictive personality and it will hinder
your other processes where you're trying
to do things because now your mind
requires this kind of dopaminergic
reaction and number three because it
purifies you and doing the opposite and
restraining yourself will increase your
resilience and your willpower and your
Islamic uh resolution and your what you
would call steadfastness with that I
will conclude don't forget to click the
link below for the
charity